à quelques kilomètres de bordeaux
l'entre-deux-mers la plus vastes terres
viticoles de france une région qui
abrite de très nombreuses appellations
côtes de bordeaux loupiac entre deux
mers des noms prestigieux qui font rêver
les investisseurs étrangers
le domaine de la vergne du long est un
domaine de 20 hectares et parmi lesquels
on a quinze hectares de vignes plantées
par ces dans laquelle se trouve sur une
parcelle de sauvignon blanc d'un peu
plus d'un hectare
on est sur une production entre dix et
douze mille bouteilles par année
voilà on privilégie la qualité à la
quantité
ici on produit du vin bio un parti pris
qui a séduit le nouveau propriétaire un
groupe industriel chinois li luc suggère
le domaine pour cette holding
spécialisée dans le textile c'est le
premier à matisse mans qu'on a fait à
l'étranger
donc pour ces étapes là on est cuit
temps sur le sio tous les niveaux donc
monsieur leproux un pitch est un
vignoble et son château du 19e siècle
d'une valeur de plusieurs millions
d'euros
nous n'en saurons pas plus sans compter
les investissements en matériel et les
nouveaux plants de vigne mais face au
boom de la consommation de vin en chine
la holding ne compte pas s'arrêter en si
bon chemin
c'est un classement plutôt stratégique
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
après deux ans de tasha et de entretenir
ce shadow vraiment une façon bio bilotte
biodynamique
on apprend même dans le métier et en
même temps aujourd'hui on cherche un
autre cible et pour trouver la perle
rare elle demande conseil à liliane
agent immobilier spécialiste des
vignobles a chuté en vignoble important
ça représente le prestige pour leurs
amis ou leurs théories sociales ses
clients des particuliers au départ mais
aussi de plus en plus souvent des
investisseurs dans le bordelais près 250
vignoble comme celui ci sont passés sous
pavillon chinois des acheteurs qui
cultive une certaine discrétion sur
votre compte vous êtes occupé de combien
de transition ça c'est qu'on fait assez
pour les investisseurs un domaine
viticole c'est désormais une danseuse un
actif de prestige un peu comme un club
de football ou un hôtel de luxe au total
2 % du vignoble français seraient
détenus par des étrangers
mais vous allez voir qu'après la vigne
qui reste un marché de luxe
les investisseurs s'intéressent
désormais à nos chances et à nos
céréales
c'est le cas dans le berry en plein
coeur de l'indre
c'est une génération complète
d'agriculteurs là qu'ils sont en train
de flamber
sambo de france qui sent bon pour moi à
l'étranger des exploitations qui
s'achète à prix d'or
après les l'ignoble prestigieux les
terres agricoles françaises sont-elles
devenues un placement comme un autre il
n'y a pas de préoccupation particulière
parce que les investisseurs sont chinois
le risque c'est la financiarisation
après derrière qu'un individu chinois
allemands ou je ne sais quoi viennent
exploiter en france ça pose pas de
problème a priori à personne c'est un
problème de souveraineté de grand choix
de société par rapport aux sols
agricoles et il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilant l'enjeu alimentaire
des années 2030 2050 il en train de
s'écrire aujourd'hui vous allez
découvrir que ces investisseurs opèrent
dans le plus grand secret profitant de
certaines failles de la loi
qui sont-ils quelles sont leurs
intentions enquête sur ces investisseurs
étrangers qui font main basse sur les
terres agricoles françaises
voilà cette partie là c'est chez moi et
l'autre côté c'est tout ce que je suis
noir
jean-marc segre habite juste en face
d'une des propriétés acquises par ses
nouveaux investisseurs en septembre 2015
ouais c'est d'installer nos enfants aux
dodgers pour essayer de développer enfin
garder nous notre patrimoine ou de le
vendre tout le temps à l'étranger auront
tous partout installé ici depuis 28 ans
il a repris l'exploitation familiale
mais après lui rien n'est sûr d'autant
que ces investisseurs font grimper les
prix alors jean marc sait gré se pose
des questions assez la personne qui
prend la succession
c'est à dire dans mes fils personnes ça
les intéresse pas pour l'instant alors
si si j'ai besoin pour la suite
non une dizaine d'années peut-être que
je prendrai la retraite c'est pas que la
retraite comme touche dans notre
capitale faut jamais faut jamais cracher
dans la soupe
est-ce que c'est pas l'occasion d'en
profiter de vents de c'est une façon de
valoriser son capital on verra
en moins de deux ans cinq propriétés et
près de 2000 hectares de terres sont
passés sous pavillon chinois dans la
campagne berrichonne
du jamais vu en france jacques charlot
est installée près de clients depuis
plus de trente ans son voisin en grandes
difficultés financières a vendu ses 120
hectares de terres céréalières en
septembre 2015
ces gens là qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire exactement de cette de cette terre
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant elle
est soustraite donc aux agriculteurs
français puisque c'est des étrangers
qu'ils l'achètent
et puis dans des conditions où les
agriculteurs français ne peuvent pas
s'aligner pour autant il n'a jamais
rencontré le nouveau propriétaire
seuls quelques ouvriers agricoles
viennent exploiter les terres en toute
discrétion il ya eu dernièrement une
période de semis là pour les printemps
donc toutes les chansons se met
maintenant ils s'aiment et s'en vont en
coin la personne qui restaient sur place
depuis la vente son ancien voisin a
quitté le département
nous nous sommes rendus dans cette
exploitation
vous
aucun salarié présent ce jour là
la propriété semble à l'abandon
nous décidons de nous rendre en caméra
cachée dans les autres exploitations du
département
racheté par ces investisseurs étrangers
bonjour on voulait savoir si c'était
viennent ici que l'europe on y en avait
racheté des terres dans l'indre céder
des parts d'accor vous avez essayé vous
avez cédé conviennent par vous cet
ancien propriétaire ne dira rien de plus
un peu plus loin sur une autre
exploitation cette fois c'est un
régisseur visiblement agacé par les
questions des journalistes qui nous
refuse l'entrée
mais vous vous travailler ici comme
exploitant
un franc succès nous nous procurons les
extrait kbis les fiches d'identité des
sociétés qui exploitent ces terres
agricoles un nom revient à chaque fois
celui du gérant un certain marc
fressange
un homme d'affaires français qui a fait
fortune dans l'import export de 20 entre
la france et la chine
c'est ce qu'il indique dans une
interview accordée en 2014 à la
télévision d'état chinoise
je suis mal fressange je suis en chine
depuis quatre ans cinq ans je suis
directeur président général de la
société ouh la la france que j'ai fondée
il ya donc cinq ans non je crois que ça
arrive avant tout politique
je suis très attentif et ce soit une
aventure collective il sert désormais
d'intermédiaire entre ces vendeurs
français et des investisseurs chinois
loin bien loin du commerce du vin le
voici en octobre 2015 avec l'un des
agriculteurs qui a vendu son
exploitation
nous avons tenté de le contacter sans
succès
deux autres noms reviennent à plusieurs
reprises dans ces sociétés begyn reward
internacional trade un groupe aux
multiples activités détergents ménagers
immobilier mais aussi production
laitière et son président un certain vu
quelqu'un en octobre 2015 il est même
venu avec une délégation en visite dans
l'indre pour l'achat de ces
exploitations avec toujours à ses côtés
marc fressange
des investisseurs étrangers qui achètent
des terres en france le phénomène n'a
rien de nouveau
ce qui change c'est la méthode discrète
mais efficace
comment ces investisseurs chinois ont
ils fait pour acquérir près de 2000
hectares de terres agricoles dans ce
département sans éveiller les soupçons
des pouvoirs publics
bonjour à toutes et à tous en france il
existe pourtant un organisme chargé de
surveiller les transferts de propriétés
dans le foncier agricole pour le compte
de l'état la safer oui on est où là il
se passe quelque chose il ya des grosses
surfaces qui ont bougé
on n'est pas notifiée et quand on a
regardé un petit peu qui était derrière
on a vu un moment donné qu'on a pu
consolider un certain nombre
d'exploitations et c'est là qu'on s'est
rendu compte que ça représente et 1700
hectares que c'était les mêmes personnes
qui détenaient les capitaux concrètement
les investisseurs profite d'une faille
pour contourner la safer à chaque fois
c'est le même type de transaction ils
n'achètent pas les terres mais des parts
de la société agricole qui possède ses
terres si le vendeur garde au moins 1%
des parts la safer ne peut rien faire
ce montage financier est parfaitement
légal l'état ne peut exercer son droit
de préemption que 600 % de la propriété
change de mains on avait à l'époque sous
forme de boutade dit mais si on met 100
% les gens vendront 99 ou 98%
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé dans
l'indre les chinois ont acquis 98 % des
parts sociales et les anciens
exploitants sont restés pour 1 ou 2 %
dans la société
le modèle qui est en train de se mettre
en place si on ne contrôle pas c'est un
modèle financier où on a des parts c'est
certaines exploitations n'ont même pas
de gérants le gérant c'est une autre
société
mais ce qui l'inquiète le plus c'est le
prix de ces transactions déconnecté du
marché aujourd'hui pour acquérir ces
sociétés sont prêts à mettre beaucoup
plus cher entre deux et trois fois plus
cher que le prix du marché
donc imaginez qu'en plus on est en train
de modifier complètement l'equilibre qui
s'était fait donc la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française des prix allant
jusqu'à quinze mille euros l'hectare
du jamais vu dans le département où le
prix moyen est de 5000 euros l'hectare
pourquoi une telle flambée pour
comprendre nous décidons d'appeler l'un
des anciens propriétaires qui a vendu à
ce groupe chinois et souhaite garder
l'anonymat
et personne qui voulait racheter mais
les safer les ça ça vous en trouvez
personne des prix des lecteurs que vous
avez vendu il s'élève à combien
d'accords et parce que vous en faites
vous n'avez pas vendu que la terre
j'imagine vous avez vendu aussi le
matériel enfin certain nombre de choses
donc quand on entend des gens dire ses
15000 euros l'hectare c'est faux c'est
ce que vous me dites d'accord
un prix qui correspond donc à une sorte
de forfait comprenant les terres bien
sûr mais aussi les bâtiments le matériel
est souvent les dettes contractées par
les anciens propriétaires rien
d'exorbitant donc mais ramené à
l'hectare cela représente une petite
fortune
les conséquences directes sur les
agriculteurs du secteur c'est que les
propriétaires se réfère à ce que ces
transactions et les propriétaires
veulent vendre ce prix là c'est des
transactions qui ont tendance à devenir
des références et ça ne peut pas
s'imposer on l'agriculteur français ne
pourra jamais acheté ce prix là
d'autant que ce prix risquent de se
répercuter sur le calcul des droits de
succession et de la taxe foncière une
catastrophe pour toute la profession
la situation préoccupe les
parlementaires au sénat c'est le
républicain daniel grémillet qui s'est
emparée du dossier il auditionne la
safer pour déterminer la réponse
législative adapté la question est ce
que l'agriculture est ce que le modèle
agricole restera paysan est ce que on
donne la capacité à des jeunes non issus
d'une meilleure école d'accéder au
métier d'agriculteur
c'est aussi un choix c'est une nécessité
cécilia haut doubs s'est installé dans
cette exploitation il y a huit ans une
reconversion pour cette jeune
trentenaire
après plusieurs années dans les
ressources humaines ici c'est plus la
partie fruits et potagers elle cultive
du safran et des fruits bio l'abaya des
framboises et là il ya 400 pieds de
fraises genre mais encore de ce côté ci
mais oui l'idée c'est quand même de
s'agrandir il faudrait au moins deux
mille pieds de fraises des péchés et
cetera peut-être vendre chaque chaque
sorte de fruitiers donc oui
effectivement il m'aurait fallu un petit
peu plus de place c'est sur 2 à 3
hectares de terres mais lorsqu'elle a
voulu acheter des parts elle à son
voisin le verdict est tombé
moi quand j'ai demandé à la personne qui
a des terres qui juxtapose les miennes
de me vendre deux hectares le jour où il
partira en retraite
il m'a dit bien sûr je peux t'en vends
de deux hectares pour 20000 euros judy
les deux ça fait beaucoup dit non
l'hectare tu vas 1000 euros l'hectare
oui oui vingt mille euros c'est le prix
qu'on me propose mais si ça vaut pas ça
de plus cet hymne ans ne pas vendre ma
maison pour acheter un hectare après je
sais quoi se poser nue re dessus
impossible pour des agriculteurs
français de s'installer à ces tarifs là
moi ça me dévore pourquoi on est pas un
jeunes agriculteurs à s'installer
pourquoi il a tellement de projets il ya
tellement de belles choses à faire c'est
pas ça que j'avais envisagé en
m'installant au milieu d'un champ d'une
butte de ferme côte-à-côte quoi c'est
pas comme ça que vous envisagez ma vie
je suis pas parti dans le centre ville
pour matches achetés au milieu des
champs pour pourvoir les choses viraient
comme ça quoi
c'est une génération complète
d'agriculteurs là qu'ils sont en train
de flinguer dans 20 ans on récupèrera
quoi nos enfants ils auront quoi
jusqu'ici la france est un pays qui
installe beaucoup encore de jeunes
agriculteurs et c'est tant mieux
et ça doit le rester donc là l'intérêt
stratégique pour l'homicide de la grippe
tue aujourd'hui c'est de garder tout les
moyens qui permettent demain d'installer
des jeunes agriculteurs
stéphane le foll a décidé de lancer une
enquête
comme il l'annoncé dans l'émission
preuves par 3 le 19 avril 2016 c'est un
sujet sur lequel l' alerte est
clairement donné je vais mettre en place
juridiquement avec le conseil général de
l'agriculture une mission pour qu'on
évalue et qu'on me dise comment on peut
faire pour empêcher que les safer n'ai
pas pu repérer ce qui s'était passé
la mission remettra ses conclusions en
septembre prochain mais en attendant les
parlementaires veulent agir et utiliser
le projet de loi sur la transparence le
projet de loi sapin 2 qui comporte un
chapitre sur la situation financière des
exploitations agricoles
le député socialiste dominique potier a
déposé un amendement pour renforcer le
contrôle des affaires et éviter que de
nouvelles acquisitions ne passent entre
les mailles du filet aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils sont en société pour posséder du
foncier agricole sont moins contrôlés
que ceux qui sont pour des structures
aux familiales ou coopérative classique
c'est une injustice patente il fallait
la dénoncer en clair permettre à la
safer d'intervenir sur ces transactions
même quand l'intégralité de la propriété
n'est pas transféré c'est un enjeu de
notre avenir collectif et seule la loi
en posant des limites peut permettre de
répondre à ce défi
mais pour le sénateur l'est républicain
daniel grémillet rapporteur sur le volet
agriculture de ce texte il ne faut pas
légiférer dans la précipitation ses
ministres au moment de ces auditions le
texte qui était étudié n'avait plus rien
à voir avec le texte final ce qui pousse
comme un vrai problème pour lui le sujet
est trop important pour être noyé dans
un texte plus général
je suis très gêné je ne vous cache pas
par ce texte de loi parce que c'est un
texte un peu fourre-tout on y met tous
soudainement ça apparaît c'est un vrai
dossier mais qui aurait mérité d'être
traitée plus profondément que le un seul
article ça mérite un travail plus
profond le sénateur envisage de déposer
une proposition de loi entièrement
consacré à ce sujet mais la loi n'est
pas rétroactive pour ces exploitations
qui sont déjà passés sous pavillon
étranger en france
l'état ne peut exproprier des
propriétaires terriens sauf dans des cas
très limités
autre piste explorée par le gouvernement
l'interdiction d'exploiter elle dépend
notamment du ministère de l'agriculture
pour l'instant deux des sociétés
représentant la majorité des terres
achetées ont été mises en demeure faute
de demande d'exploitation
il nous reste maintenant un point ce
contrôle des structures c'est à dire que
l'état autorise ou non l'exploitation
à condition bien sûr que les critères
pour l'exploitation soit remplie et donc
cette société constituée dans le berry
n'a toujours pas eu l'autorisation
d'exploiter alors qu'est ce qu'ils
feront ils ont des propriétés
ils ont racheté des thermes et pourront
rien en faire et justement que quand ils
en faire de ses terres quelles sont les
intentions de ces investisseurs
pour en savoir plus nous nous rendons en
caméra cachée à la coopérative qui
collectent la production de l'une de ces
exploitations visiblement nos questions
dérangent
bonjour monsieur on avait un
renseignement à vous demander en fait on
voulait savoir si les c1 de suite c'est
du gaumont revenez ici du tout
pourtant ils sont vraiment un côté là
nous disons parce qu'on voulait pas
répondre sur cette chaussée selon nous
n'en saurons pas plus l'ancien
propriétaire lui a sa petite idée et
voulons dit ce qu'il comptait faire de
la production
depuis la crise financière de 2008 la
terre fait office de valeur refuge
un peu comme l'or
pour le président de la chambre
d'agriculture de l'indre c'est le calcul
qu'on fait ces investisseurs chinois
certains investisseurs souhaitent
sécuriser en se disant je vais pas avoir
une rentabilité et non toujours est il
que je perdrais pas d'argent et
éventuellement comme les terres n'arrête
pas d'augmenter depuis une trentaine
d'années c'est un phénomène
c'est un phénomène récurrent quand je
revendrai j'aurais pas perdu d'argent et
j'en aurais sans doute de gagner dont
j'aurai une plus-value faire une plus
value sans doute mais pas seulement
il ya quand même une finalité économique
au agricole économico alimentaire qui
quand même sous jacent de voir presque
affiché aujourd'hui avec à la clé
derrière un projet de 20 mille hectares
qui pourrait arriver dans quelques
années et ça on le retrouve à peu près
partout dans les investissements chinois
qu'ils effectuent dans le foncier
la chine possède seulement 8 % des
terres cultivables pour nourrir 20% de
la population mondiale est depuis une
dizaine d'années l'état comme les
investisseurs chinois achètent des
terres un peu partout dans le monde
principalement en asie du sud-est en
afrique en océanie est désormais en
europe
plusieurs pays se sont dotés de
législation très stricte pour lutter
contre l'accaparement des terres
agricoles comme la hongrie et la pologne
d'autres comme la nouvelle zélande ont
bloqué certaines transactions au nom de
l'intérêt national
en france visiblement le groupe reward
ne compte pas s'arrêter là
après une première visite en octobre
la holding a de nouveau envoyé une
délégation en février 2016 pour visiter
une usine de production de farine est
une coopérative laitière
pour autant la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays est elle menacée pas
encore avec quelques milliers d'hectares
de terres agricoles achetées sur les 28
millions que compte la france
mais suffisamment pour mettre en alerte
les pouvoirs publics